what does friendship mean to you
friendship means having someone you can
count on no matter what great for bar
tops table tops game boards clocks
plaques ceramics you might remember from
the 360 camera on an arrow video we sort
of broke nicos bow I don't really want
to go as far as to say that it's it's
been physically broken for us to say
that it's been physically slightly
damaged Niko has been a little bit weird
since his boat broke it meant a lot to
him he's been kind of distant he stopped
using punctuation and emojis and all of
his text messages I feel like the light
is kind of died a little bit and Niko
we need our Niko back we need we need
the cheery spry young man that we've all
come to know and love and we need him
back in here I think and so it's time to
fix the bow when you make a promise to
somebody you follow through on it if you
borrow something and you damage it you
fix it come take a look at this this is
a Niko's deceased uncle's bow which Niko
got as an heirloom from him I don't
think we actually truly assess the
damage in the last video right here you
see this come look super close do you
see this yeah so there's that and you
see that there's a little notch right
here varnish is peeling right here
that's it that's the entirety of damage
in this know that was already there no
that wasn't none of this was here all
the scuffs this was already here this
was already here I don't know what else
to say about that a few years ago I
built a bar I like a drinking bar yes a
drinking bar when you pass the bar one
thing's for sure you're going to need a
bar when I finish that bar top I used
this pour on finish it's a two-part
enamel and it creates a thick coat you
know when you go to bars and they have
the pictures that are in the bar top and
the bar top looks like it's made out of
glass that's this stuff basically
creates this glass like enamel creates a
really nice super glaze clear finish on
it which is very similar to what Niko
already has on here so all I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna pour a tiny bit of this
into a mixing Cup I'm going to lightly
sand away some of this stripping plastic
fiber and then I'm just going to apply
with a brush a tiny bit of glaze on here
to create a smooth finish
again over the top when you finish this
stuff to keep bubbles out of it you want
to take a blowtorch and very lightly
just like flick the flame this should be
able to handle that task just fine very
lightly I'm gonna do this I'm kind of
nervous this isn't my bow this is it's
working here in this divot I'm trying to
keep this sliver but and you tell it
needs something to press it down onto
the bow to apply pressure maybe a tiny
dab of superglue just to keep it down
and then the epoxy can set in around it
there's a lot of different ways you
could solve a problem like this and I'm
by no means a professional Fletcher I'm
sure there's a lot of good opinions on
how to do this and what type of epoxy to
use and resin to use and just saying
I've used this before it worked this is
a very simple problem and so it requires
a simple solution I'm just gonna make
sure that this resin is nice and smooth
now and it's pretty much all we're gonna
need to do gents
I don't think I need to actually mess
with it anymore you don't want to overdo
this because they can get outta hand
real quick you already know the answer
to what I'm about to say just don't say
it rot over this weekend went up around
250,000 hits or more why do you think
that might have happened - I'm gonna
take a wild guess that's related to a
fan game that came out and that fan game
earlier he knew a wild guess at all
here's what happened I got I got a
message on Instagram hey you should
check this out alright what's going on
like I really don't watch let's play
videos ago it's markiplier so I press
play and I start going seems really
familiar and it turns out someone
created a video directly inspired for
this short it's crazy now this one is
gonna start out with one called brought
I know I'm clapping bit about bunny boo
boo boo
this one's called rod and it looks
fantastic it looks so good I actually
had to go into my game settings or my
card set my computer I hadn't used my
Wizarding magic to zap my computer into
something that could actually record and
handle this game at the same time and I
don't know what this game is about what
we're gonna find out right now I
actually don't even know if there's a
straight-up horror game right well I
already have a problem here because I'm
starting this out in the middle seat and
I don't know who volunteered for the
middle received my keys in the back of
my hand is a few a few inches too far
forward from my face and just able to
turn right a little too much political
Samsung
oh hi glad you started the light show
back up
Oh
[Music]
yeah that's I need to go to the top
comments it's a soap creation isn't that
crazy and then I'm sure all of you guys
know this but this week is going to be
my last week here hopefully I can come
back around December January with
everybody hoping when I'm done with
about 72 hours for the super glaze to
dry now let's see what the finished
result is yeah it worked pretty well you
know I could even add a little bit more
but totally fine
it's and a little bit of it off well I
think it could use more honestly you
tell me if it's mixed
Jake this looks pretty fixed to me you
did a great job man thank you son can't
even tell
now does this qualify me as a Fletcher
now does it yeah in hindsight we
definitely should have just taken a tiny
little wooden dowel I could have printed
a little mount for it
Oh see this you see this I want you to
tell me if you think it's done if I can
do more to it if you want how'd it go I
was able to save that the fibers this is
looking good here yeah I think you might
have a bit of an issue here with Haas
trumpeters yeah I know if you could
smooth it out yeah I was thinking about
adding more into that damn it divot
ideally if you're a blind person
your hand should go across it you
shouldn't feel that yeah that was smooth
then because when there was always going
across there it's gonna write grateful
feathers this part here can use some
lacquer also yeah and this wasn't this
isn't you guys this is a pad there's a
little I'll sand it and then seal sand
it and seal it and so you can get rid of
this Ridge if we can't get rid of this
Ridge we might have to do so you can get
rid of that Ridge okay yeah it's just a
matter of applying more into here so you
don't feel this event it's looking good
man cool it's real good cool I'm gonna
sand this down slightly and then just
apply more of the glaze so we were two
different areas divot cream in as well
as right here that's pretty much it
she's gonna make some minor adjustments
and be done now we left the secured Tom
Monday I showed Tanika ven and given
where he was at with the additional
improvements I've made here I think he's
gonna love it
I got a question for you Sam do you ever
worry with people coming in out of the
team that it reflects weird when we make
a show out of all the characters in the
studio everybody that works here is also
on camera tail does that reflect poorly
what's the question she's like do you
ever worry that like you know in a TV
show when a character leaves it's a big
deal usually but here you know people's
jobs and want other things and but their
character leaves you ever worried that
people get attached to a character and
the character was gone like to put our
to our employment life so publicly like
never worry about it reflecting poorly
on us I don't think it reflects poorly
no if anything I would say we don't make
it into a bigger like I don't think we
didn't make it into big enough of a deal
people leave that people we're here
we're used to it we're in the business
of it and we understand that things are
more complex and reality when people
come and go but when you watch it
as a show or as a vlog or something like
that you're not always getting the full
story it does feel like a big deal it's
like watching a show and like the
character daxing like well did anyone
not see that like they left they're gone
forever oh my god like all the
characters just continue on with their
lives like that character is important
that's I feel like what the effect is
like is every was like oh Adrian oh oh
no that sucks he's leaving now that was
a big deal yeah I don't know that's nice
to say I think we could I mean what do
you think do you think it's telling why
I'm asking you you have no context we
have all the context over the weekend I
learned a new trick that I'm super proud
of it took me over a year to learn it
and it clicked on Saturday and then I
spent all day sunday practicing it and I
know how to go up a curb now the problem
is that in the process of me learning I
abused this front float plate so much
that I start stripping the screws out of
the holes I installed what are called
float plates from the float life is the
plastic shields that you strap to the
bottom of the one-wheel but here's the
thing I want to keep doing these tricks
but I don't want to do the tricks
without the flip plate so I wanted to
try to repair this just to point out I
was not given this one wheel I bought
this with my own money I know that this
is worth every penny even though I spent
a lot of money on this I will use it but
I was salary here at corridor that is
partially funded by you viewers if
specifically you patrons I want to give
a thank you to the top tier patrons all
of you watching that put a little bit of
sprinklin money filipok circus oh hey
we're about to have a hang
here in like three hours to talk
one-to-one because that's also a patreon
tier stop Phillips talk two and three
hours set the mad scientist
Gandalf Oh Gary Dolph Gary Dolph I
thought your name was gandalf dude we
have Nathan MacFarlane Aidan rights we
have Nicholas Psaltis and we have G
squared
you know what up G squared shows that GG
is that like GG to the D take the actual
awesome thanks to Taylor Dunbar oh man
we got these sinus screws Thank You
Colin heatman he didn't you always
pronounce the t's with a heart T button
yeah yeah panties we have Mitch Polinsky
thanks to glitch cube as well oh and of
course we also have James Bailey James
James Bailey's been around for a while
y'all lastly thank you to Brian and
toesik those are our top gear patrons if
you want to learn more about our patreon
and want to support us I am going to gas
taped this but the gap tape going
underneath the front foot pad this is
not a long-term solution this is just a
band-aid I want some suggestions on the
best ways to attach the screw to a bit
of like a stripped out situation here
right
[Music]
[Music]
true it's finally upon us let me get the
spell in here how's it look it looks
smooth dude that's the other thing yeah
feel that nice yeah now the question is
should I stand down so it's not quite as
glossy forget it with that fine fine
yeah that's super fine I sanded it down
a bit more and I gotta say I can't even
tell that it was broken it looks and
feels beautiful that the edge is nice
and smooth that's not it's not sharp
anymore an arrow should fly right off of
this thing as if it was the day that it
was made Hey
I believe this is your bow believe it is
just let me know if it's your bow well
that feels good look at that smooth no
ridges there this is all sealed up feels
good no ridges there either
I'm impressed Jake thanks man the first
coat of finish that I applied created a
substance that I could then sand to make
it nice and smooth yeah that's good I
think it'll shoot true I think I need to
go find out I think it went pretty well
he seemed pretty happy with the bow
hopefully it shoots straight and true
because it used to before and I think I
think it will again there's probably
other types of lacquers and things like
that or other techniques that hey come
back out and try hitting some targets I
hear arrows flying dude
beautiful diet I have actually nice you
want to get your bull's-eyes arrows to
be sliding off the air rest just fine
I'm gonna even top left why I've not
seen any wobble or feeling any
scratching or that bridge thanks for
fixing it you're welcome
yeah appreciate it yeah thanks for
letting us use it in all the videos it's
an honor well you know if you remember
somebody's legacy with an item you got
to keep using that item just having it
sit on the shelf is same as throwing it
away so you want take a couple shops
yeah love to should we buy it though for
the channel views no now with friends
like this guys
my second favorite thing to do in life
is sabre champagne bottles and since
this is Adrienne's last day I figured he
should save her a champagne bottle and
get trophy is so easy I've never done
this you've never done it do you know
what it is I've seen it I've seen people
do it yeah let's start by picking out
the blade do you want to use Oh we're
supplying blades buying this blade I can
barely pick up say British champagne is
awesome because you're in high spirits
why else would you take a sword and a
glass bottle and create a small
pressurized explosion savoring champagne
is super super easy because it's all
about hitting a single precise point on
the bottle which is very easy to find
we're gonna look for the seam when the
bottle is created there's these two ends
that meet and then are kind of connected
here together one of the weakest points
on the bottle is right here right where
that seam touches that first lip just
imagine my hands the sword take it and
you just push shape right and right when
it hits that lip whole thing will go
Adrian yes do your worst
all right this is the first time I've
ever saber that's a bottle of champagne
maybe the last and yet quite possibly
Fidel flame
we got a playing in it all right perfect
first try masterful thank you Sam for
teaching there we go Hayden I'm sad that
you are going to miss we get 200 I told
you hit me up when you're filming janky
I'll come up for free to help you know
I'm gonna paste one of your film
pictures of you on my monitor like a
fallen soldier a fallen comrade
hey guys do you guys thanks Adrian yep
yeah that's good stuff Danny start in
the desert right